[Applause]
nice fall day in LA County sit and
watching all the leaves change
temperatures dipping into the low 70s
accordingly
[Music]
roll down the window put down the top
you know what maybe roll it up on second
thought a guy was higher than the
pension of the state employees
[Music]
my god
you can park it
toilet flushing but the sun is shining
all the time
group like a noble build of pain I love
LA
we love it
[Music]
we love it definitely recommend this
crystal here oh and this one is our
number one seller ah what's that for
anxiety and though typhus
public school graduates can family read
and when they try to pop well this is
what
three regulations ain't nothing like him
nowhere
[Music]
Pizza
we love it
we love it
River sad will make streets
unfortunately I'll have to fail your
restaurant I found a rat in the kitchen
I wasn't a rat that was my emotional
support rodent well why didn't you say
so
and this right here is a great
hemorrhoidal crystal Uranus is in
retrograde
I love
we love
I love LA
[Music]
wait
[Applause]
[Music]